[Music]
foreign
a dead guy shows up in my door
Revenge
should have stayed dead
I can get in I can get in
I know I repeat myself
you're ruin my snacks
an ax
I don't want to fight you and this is
gonna end quick
Letty
Buddy's in a black site prison off of
every map and get her out nobody can
nobody would Dom I'm so sorry but
what you're asking me to do is
impossible
[Music]
nothing's impossible
just have that fit
[Music]
moving to Despicable
get out of there
[Applause]
getting tricky guys I can't stay on them
for much longer
you remember my father
is
my father was a horrible man
very bad daddy
but I kind of liked him and you took him
from me when you stole our money he left
us with nothing but suffering
for
the and the suffering
oh and I didn't take that money
burned it
hold on
[Music]
I got eyes on Uncle muscle and the kid
all right everybody remember the plan
containing kidnap thank you
no no guns
alive
at least for a while
you ready ready
[Music]
thank you
holy shh Oh no you're good you're good
okay song lyrics stub toes and Tanning
cars
foreign
so we've been on a lockdown Highway a
big Highway two lanes on each side even
when you're ready all right guys check
in please and these two helicopters come
in on either side and they skewer into
the side of Dom's car and try and pick
him up here we go and three two one and
Dom keeps fighting them like crazy and
as he gets the back into hit one last
time he hits the NOS
[Applause]
jumps from one freeway three two one go
over to the other freeway and lands on
the other side helicopters land in a big
burning hole behind it
so that's it
what's it
you know we don't really be there if
Roman wasn't driving Fort Knox on wheels
you see me shining baby
we'll lock this up it's a trap that's
the bomb all right dorks what are we
blowing up what the Vatican wow you guys
are going to hell
oh
the great Dom Toretto if you never would
have gotten behind that wheel
I'd never be the man I am today
and now I'm the man who's going to break
your family
Peace by peace the devil's coming
dummy I knew you would come for me well
how about we all just start shooting
each other time to endless
let's dig some Graves
you are not to be trusted are you in on
my Christmas list either
calvary's here
cheers we need weapons and cars
cabin cars do you like surprises I adore
them
I'd stay down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that
the game's over down you lose
your last ride
then you might want to buckle up
that was the scene when I read it I was
just like I can't wait to see Letty
fighting I was like oh that's me she's
kicking my ass this is amazing good
morning sunshine you gotta be kidding me
we have a nice one-on-one battle she's a
tough cookie so we'll see what happens
you're welcome we had to take this fight
and make it the best fight that ever was
in The Fast and Furious friendship it
was like you have two live fighting each
other this vital story you have Charlize
who doesn't want to fight and Michelle
really want to kill the Charlize letty's
pretty angry in this scene sometimes I
was like they're really going to fight
when you see Michelle strike the first
time it's an explosion now is that so
hard
laughs
the way Michelle Rodriguez sells action
with her body with her eyes you just
believe it she's so badass even when we
train her she surprises she's like a
crazy cat you know she go in all the
directions I'd stay down if I was you
when you see Charlize Theron walk
towards you and look you straight into
your eyes it makes you feel very small
she has so much Soul she's a monster to
battle with I gotta say Obviously Cipher
is very technical she's very well
trained lety's more of a street fighter
her power comes from the heart so it's
interesting to see the two fighting
styles go at it together
there were moments where she'd come at
me and I got scared I was like
they both get each other but they scare
me even more I mean the two of them
together when they do this and I'm like
cut and they turn to me I'm like okay
ladies
easy can you take one note yes
this is the fight that the audience has
been waiting for since
2017. and wow does it deliver
I've never seen a movie like this
we're revving to give you everything we
got
we got something special so let's
celebrate that it's the end of the road
so we're going back to the roots of Fast
and Furious
let's dig some Graves then I go what
kind of trouble can we get into this
time everything is bigger better and
hits you like a right hand of the jaw
it is True Entertainment on a massive
canvas you're about to learn all about
fear with a new villain with new Stakes
real steak I hadn't played a villain in
probably 10 years all right dorks what
are we blowing up I wanted to bring
something to the lineage that hadn't
been done yet he just comes in guns
blazing you guys are going to hell
Dante is really one angry guy but really
well dressed to face off against Dom and
his family you had to be a certain
psychotic he's coming for you with
everything
there's something coming and dumb knows
it I can't think of a better time for
him to be at a Crossroads never accept
that
offering is old we're all feeling unsure
at the moment even down
we haven't been as successful as we're
used to seeing this team be and that's
kind of scary
this sets the stage for something larger
so it's unfamiliar territory that's the
problem with having such a big family
how do you choose the ones you save
I really am looking forward to the
toretos being back together again we're
firing on all cylinders
exciting yes
he's trying to tear us apart is it
nerve-wracking hell yeah this is the
magic of fast Let's Race it's showtime
we go it's the beginning of the end it's
the sum of everything we've loved in the
Fast and Furious Universe here they come
it's exciting to be a piece in the
puzzle of something that's so very
important pop culture I do suggest for
the audience out there to prep it's a
big one for a socket to be complete it
must have an ending it's bittersweet but
dare I say more meaningful
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]